and what happened here so first of all
we haven't even talked about it giannis
is a champion which is a beautiful thing
to see a guy get 50
greek freak 17 for 19 13 rebounds five
zen called it and
nba finals series featuring bucks and
sons attracts 9.9 million viewers
up 32 from 2020 but still down from
previous year go a little lower here
because lebron the last game of the nba
uh uh final series featured in milwaukee
was on twelve and a half million viewers
on tw uh
50 compared to game six of 2020 which
was played in october because of coveted
pantheon but overall the series
for a few of years in the year before
the bucks of nancy finally so
here's what i liked about this series
okay
uh first of all you know for six games
i heard nothing about politics there was
no blm there was no people are bad there
was no nothing it was just a great
series okay that you sat there and
watched fantastic series
and this guy here for whatever reason
the nba is having a hard time helping
him be the face of the nba
there's something about him that scares
him he said i had the opportunity to go
to another super team
i didn't want to do it just not
something what i wanted to do i wanted
to stay here and win the championship i
could have easily gone to another super
team shot to everybody in that league
too
everybody in the league gets called out
stephen a smith says chris middleton
should win mvp and uh he ends up winning
mvp absolutely absolutely showing
everybody that this guy's the mvp
a performance no one's ever seen before
what does he do he takes every argument
away by the way
they're asking chris paul chris what are
you going to be doing he's like i'm not
going to talk about it right now what
i'm going to be doing in the offseason
we just lost man leave us alone and
we'll i'll kind of let you know chris
paul is leaving phoenix
chris paul is leaving phoenix i'm
willing to bet on it that paul is
leaving phoenix
l.a and he's going to go one of couple
places he if he goes to la it's not
going to be just lebron's call from to
go to l.a
boss and some of the other guys have to
agree for him to go to la paul's leaving
phoenix
he's going to go to a different place
booker is going to win here
i'm going to tell you right now booker
is going to win here because everybody
in the league is sitting there saying
who do i want as a teammate
and people are saying i want booker as a
teammate i don't know if i want paul as
a teammate
he's going to get attention either
booker's going to go somewhere a book is
going to sit there and say i'm more like
giannis than i'm like all these other
guys
what if i stay in phoenix what if i
attract a couple guys that come run with
me
what if we go out there actually win a
championship what if he attracts a
couple players i want to go wrong with
them
but anyways one thing one thing is for
sure when it comes down to the nba right
now especially with what's going on with
lebron not being in this thing he was
playing a whole thing with space jam
while he's in the finals it was going to
be this big blockbuster deal
kind of didn't work out for him you're
hearing behind closed doors
guys talking about they should trade
steven a you know
anthony davis for damian lillard the
chris paul should come to the lakers all
these talks are being done
i applaud giannis class act humble
says all the right things is still being
himself and it still respects lebron
still respects kobe still respects all
these guys they asked him a question
they said so in 2007
when lebron got into the league he says
do you remember when this took place he
says i wasn't even playing basketball
yet
he started playing basketball the first
time in oh eight first time he played
basketball was a no wait it's 13 years
ago the guy's 26 years old
first time he played basketball was at
13 14 years old and now he is who he is
today so
it's great for the nba i hope the nba
welcomes him
i hope the nba allows him to become the
face i hope this guy wins back to back
to back i hope he becomes the new face
that attracts people
from all walks of life to say i can be
an nba fan again and i'm not going to be
judged
for what i stand for here's a question
for you one crazy question for you
ready which sport have you heard
nothing about politics in that sport the
nhl
nothing there is nothing with
politics you hear it in football
kaepernick
you hear it in the nba non-stop you hear
it in the mlb
non-stop got a question for you about
the nba here's a question for you
question for all you guys name me a
republican in the nfl
a player in the nfl nfl tom brady tumblr
okay great
name me a republican in the mlb uh
ninety percent of the league
ninety percent leader name your
republican in the nba
oh yeah the guy jonathan isaac that
wouldn't know anybody
i'm talking about name me a half decent
star in the nba that's a republican
outwardly that you even know that's a
republican
i don't or a libertarian or an
independent anybody they're out there
they're just not vocals made me one you
you
have friends yeah i have friends do you
have anybody that you know is
that what that is republican 100 you do
yes
charles barkley i don't know if charles
burke are they vocal can they be vocal
about it yeah we've got someone
that can come in here and even come on
the podcast are they vocal about it yeah
they've talked about it while they're
playing that they're supporting on the
right they're retired now they're not
playing
i understand who you're talking about
but outside of him tell me somebody else
who's a star
and he wasn't a star but i'm talking
about somebody that was a star is he a
republic
a republican i'm i'm i'm thinking if
there's a star in the league right now
that will come
out and say that there's a that they're
republican i don't know lebron james
would let them
i don't know i don't think lebron
controls the league like he did at one
point
can you today come out and say you're
republican in the nba see i
i i think you can't like can you i don't
know but
should you yes but if you do will your
career be negatively employed yeah i
think that's [ __ ] yeah
but yeah i think you could say i'm a
republican this is what i agree with
good for you
i believe in social justice like you can
be a republican and still
what's even social question for you most
people that work for vitamin are they
democrats or republicans
uh it's pretty split pretty split yeah
shocking number of communists
but what i'm saying to you i don't think
there's anything what i'm saying to you
is it's a split
yeah it's a split here right there so is
america so is america
right but not the nba but but not the
nba
okay yeah but but here's one percentage
of the nba we talked about this
yeah but we talked about this here
though we're in florida yeah and it's
joe biden
me and adam but me and i have talked
about me and adam talked about
this already this conversation
valuetainment has
split but you're talking about that for
the most part
calif florida democrats and republican
can coexist
in california they can't and neither can
they in the nba
right so what i'm getting is that you
you have a split here but everybody's
like yeah we're cool you're the
microphone
probably can be cool you don't judge
each other in california there's a lot
of judging because i know
i sure as hell do it and i'm not even
going to deny it and i'm good with it
i'm going to own the fact that yes i yes
california
there is no california like a democratic
republic like a democrat
calif democrat californians are a whole
different breed of their own
they are not they're like super mutants
they're not
like a regular democrat in florida it's
very culturally in california so yes i
do judge and yes i do
tend to stay away because i just don't
like their ideology i think what you're
saying is depending on what state you're
in
there's a like for instance there's a
difference between a um
new york democrat versus a alabama
democrat
okay yes there's a difference between a
it's regional versus new jersey
republican
versus a mississippi republican right
like there's differences california so i
didn't understand all like in florida we
coexist
yes my friends are cuban they're
republicans but they're socially liberal
or i went to school in tallahassee where
it's northern panhandle
and there's a lot of more like rural
americans not but
south beach like we kind of co-exist
california there's a lot of arguing
it's not as ugly in politics here as is
i'll be for real with you if you were up
in brooklyn have you spent a lot of time
in brooklyn specifically but new york
and north jersey in particular
they wouldn't let you claim that you're
a democrat they would they would
ostracize you either you would have to
move further to the left or your social
circles would restrict access to you i
swear to god
because you're not far enough left
they'd consider you a closet republican
or
sure and i'm okay with that i'm not
there because i would probably push you
oh you're a crowded republican no i'm
telling you right now they would flip
the zone they would push you out of
business opportunities they would push
you'd be pushed out you'd either have to
go this explains
why you're so angry so i i i am angry
i know i get it but i've never had to
deal with you do you want to be clear
i've never had a republican or democrat
say
you shouldn't do this or happen i never
said it's not both sides by the way i
just want to be clear with this
i've never said it's not both sides i
said look at the other side is the wrong
argument for right now
in this moment right now it's not both
corporate america is not cow towing to
both sides
they're cow towing to one side nba isn't
trying to win over the republican vote
they're putting up all progressive
messaging they're going as far to the
left
china china china they they've chosen
and it's not ben and jerry's
ben and jerry specific exactly so in
this moment
all i want from democrats all i want and
then you know that
here comes hamburger six nine six nine
in the comments going this is a
right-wing podcast
all i want from democrats is to just
admit it like i
love love love what
bill maher is doing yeah i love love
love what russell brand is doing
these guys are democrats i don't want
everybody to think
like me i just want you to live in the
same reality that i live in
yeah i don't gaslight me into saying
what i know to be true
isn't it like pat says the best ideas
will rise to the top the best ideas will
win
and if you're too far left and the rest
of america is like dude what are you
doing here bro
i don't i don't want everyone going into
the same bathroom
i don't want a male competing in the
softball women's softball
or power lifting this is a little too
extreme like we all like
something that we all are guilty of is
saying that the other side
are idiots the easiest way to convince
somebody is let's say i'm a democrat
and i talk to my democrat friends i'm
like guys you gotta understand you i
mean you've got kids here
you want you got you're actually good
with you know
the trans stuff going on in the bathroom
like i'm not trying to pick on a
specific issue
and me talking like that's going to go a
lot further and you're a [ __ ] idiot
and you don't understand
blah blah blah but understand like if
you're on the right side and you're like
look dude you gotta understand like man
like maybe we shouldn't attack the
capital maybe we shouldn't follow donald
trump i'll be very maybe you're right
maybe you're right let me be very
specific
megan uh rapino rapino however you say
and the rest of the women's national
team
representing us soccer team representing
us taking a knee
still dornium the ameri during the
national anthem now she had explained
this four years ago that trump was a
fascist
so she's standing up against she's
kneeling against fascism she's kneeling
against
something that okay fine that trump
isn't the guy
going door to door trying to jab people
with
foreign substances isn't the guy who
censors people's thoughts on big with
big tech
she's not the person like jen sackey
saying we're working closely with
private sectors
to to eliminate misinformation which
just happens to be information that goes
against their narrative
these are all very clearly
pseudo-fascist ideas she's still taking
the knee
trump's not in office what's the deal at
some point
here you have to be held account if
you're going to make these public
declarations you have to be held account
for them
all right and i'll be frank man if i see
the american soccer team national the
national team kneeling during our
national anthem i don't want them there
man
get out yeah give it to somebody else
you shouldn't be represented they lost
3-0 by the way so you don't have to
worry too
much the u.s women's they're not they're
not dude
they're not there they're not there
they're not doing their thing three zero
two
then she said we didn't play good games
because of climate change
yeah you can't trust these scandinavian
countries cnn story
we don't know what's going on over there
let me change it up let me change it up
i want i want to do a little bit of a
light uh uh conversation here with you
guys i want to see what you're going to
say about this okay so
question for you mr adam ricky
gerard everybody here is participating
david you're also participating kai you
are too
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye